Let's go next to our caller from the three
one nine area code.
Who's calling today from three one nine?
Hey, there it.
I'm going to call myself Tim, and I'm part
of the Yangyang here, and I'm curious to see
what your opinion is on this.
I'm actually a little different from the Angang
because I think that actually looking at the
different candidates that you're supporting
across the board, including I mean, I encourage
anybody look you guys up.
Alex Morse, an amazing candidate, and also
Dr. Robbie Goldstein.
And then another amazing candidate there in
Massachusetts.
And so I'm seeing how he's been even to my
my opinion, be more effective being outside
of being in the sun, outside political role
instead of being on the inside.
So because of that, I'm actually starting
to think I'd like a very proud card carrying
member of the Angang that you actually might
not be as effective in a presidential role
and it's might be more effective.
And it's sort of like, say, my political role.
And so I want see what your take on that is,
considering that, you know, you look at Donna.
I'm I'm in Texas 31.
She's an amazing candidate who won her primary
there.
And I would love to see her go on and win.
So I don't see what your take is on that.
I think it's completely reas.
I mean, so.
OK.
Here's the thing about Andrew Yang, one of
the critiques of Andrew Yang during the campaign.
I mean, again, remember, he never pulled more
than like two percent.
So we're talking about things in a sort of
abstract sense.
But one of the critiques of Andrew Yang during
the campaign was that maybe he had too much
of a sort of consultancy approach to politics
where everything is, you know, it's just like
project management and it's sort of like the
tainted or influenced by his entrepreneurial
background.
There were some people who were critical of
him along those lines.
The reality is that that works really well
in what you're talking about, which is he
has a sort of fixed amount of political capital
right now.
And you can be strategic about saying, okay,
he's going to get behind Alex Morris.
By the way, Alex Morse was on on my show last
week.
And this other person, he could influence
people in this way.
I think that Andrew Yang's strengths work
very naturally in building coalition and supporting
other candidates, mobilizing people, doing
interviews and getting people aware of some
of these candidates.
So I think what you're saying makes a lot
of sense.
Yeah.
And so I guess I'm just coming out from the
standpoint of personally, I guess I see his
support for a four day workweek being a much
more palatable policy.
And if I think that he actually might be more
effective and pushing, say, you know, by then
or if not by then, then some of the other
candidates for whoever comes after Biden on,
say, a four day workweek, which I think would
you know, I think that that's where I stand
in the way at the four day workweek.
Just need to, Peter.
I think so, anyway, especially in the covert
area where it seems like everybody's working
around the clock and.
Yeah.
So anyway, thanks.
Or input.
All right.
Thank you for the call.
Great to hear from you.
Where are we going to go next?
So many people holding.
It's hard to it's hard to really know.